تظهر أوروبا أنها لا تتباطأ
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتحقيق في التكنولوجيا الكبيرة
، يوم الإثنين
أكدت المفوضية الأوروبية أنها تحقق
في ممارسات جمع البيانات من Google و Facebook على
وجه التحديد ، فهي تبحث في
كيفية ولماذا تجمع Google و Facebook البيانات
بشكل خاص حول
خدمات البحث المحلية وكل ذلك على  الإعلانات
نظرًا لأن Google و Facebook
يسيطران على مجال الإعلان عبر الإنترنت ،
فقد أكدت المفوضية أنهم أرسلوا
استبيانًا كجزء من
تحقيق أولي في
الشركات وهذه التحقيقات
جزء من اتجاه طويل الأمد رأيناه
في أوروبا يتشدد في  التكنولوجيا ، لقد
حصلوا على المزيد من القواعد وضرائب خطاب الكراهية وحماية البيانات
والمنافسة
، تم بالفعل تغريم Google بالفعل
9 مليارات دولار في أوروبا منذ عام 2017
ولا يبدو أن الاتحاد الأوروبي والدول الأعضاء
فيه يتباطأ في أي وقت
قريبًا
يوم الإثنين  أعلنت هيئة المسابقات في المملكة المتحدة
أنها ستحقق في شراء
Google بقيمة 2.6 مليار دولار  حالة
علم بيانات المشاهد وما إذا كان
الاندماج سيقلل المنافسة
داخل المملكة المتحدة الآن ، لم يكتمل الاستحواذ
بعد ، ولكن حتى إذا
اكتمل ، يمكن للمملكة المتحدة مواصلة
تحقيقاتها على الرغم من كل هذه
التحقيقات وتجد أنها لم
توقف فورة الاستحواذ على Google
في الشهر الماضي فقط ، أعلنت Google عن
شرائها شركة Fitbit لتتبع اللياقة البدنية
مقابل أكثر من ملياري دولار لكل
مكتب قديم في CNN London